in
[Music]
know
good
okay
[Music]
for
Christian
[Music]
d
e
the
I'm
excited I'll give you too so good to see
you
girl hello welcome to youth Sunday I
have a couple
announcements
um we there's
a there's a fall festival for our table
community at Josh and Kelly's
house um we will have a chili cookout
some fun games for the adults and kids
alike gather around a fire pit and just
enjoy time together be on the lookout
for Fall Festival sign up in your weekly
table emails this week we also have a
special announcement about Pastor
appreciation month and we'd like to
invite Jesse watts to come share more
about
it
hey how's everyone doing so so I'm sure
all of you had marked on your calendars
that October is Pastor appreciation
month oh yeah right oh yeah yes yeah we
all liar obviously um but no hey Brett
could you come on up here for a
minute
so so y'all it has been a remarkable
Journey um for for this community for
the leaders of this community and I've
had this unique privilege to be a part
of every chapter of Brett's church
planting uh story and and so I remember
these very late night conversations
after long days of lectures at Seminary
where he would talk about a community
that's truly inclusive that's truly
authentic that is um really a table
where everyone has a seat and which is
rare there are very very few churches
that are actually like that they may say
they're like that but we all know that
they're not but he had this dream in
this vision and we talked about it for
years pretty much an entire decade um of
this dream and so I got to see him start
this community I've gotten to see him on
the days when it's going really well
there's success there's Victory and I've
been there for the deep valleys of doubt
and discouragement where we're both
looking at each other
like what are we doing um but you guys
and I'm sure you've noticed like right
now like church leaders are falling left
and right you know having a a pastor
that is truly full of Integrity Faith
dedication and is self-sacrificial is is
a rare thing right now and I'm telling
you as someone who's been there since
day one we have that we have that and so
while words and even this small gift
really
cannot encapsulate Express the depth of
our gratitude we wanted to give you as a
community as a church this small gift to
tell you that we love you and we're so
glad that you're Our
[Applause]
[Music]
Shepherd all right well as August
announced it is youth Sunday so what
better way to appreciate your pastor
than giving him a week off right that's
what we're here for
so I just wanted to introduce this is
our youth worship band and um Michael
Alvarez is over here on the guitar
Michael has been serving as one of our
youth leaders for forever two years now
I mean since we started our youth Meetup
so from day one Michael's been in on the
gig and we're so grateful to have him
this is Eden McDonald a senior at Allen
High yay um on vocals and Eve Tilford is
doing vocals and some drumming for us
tonight
woohoo and my name is Maggie I'm Eve's
mom yeah 's Mom yay Eve's
mom tonight that's my role um anyways
but yes so um I hope you guys could just
join in with us sing along we definitely
were like okay we're nervous we we're
feeling all the nerves so we could use
lots of support um so you guys would you
stand with us and we're going to get
started tonight thank you so much
all right Eve could you count us
off raise it
hallelu in the presence of my
enemies I ra it
[Music]
hallelu louder than the
unbelief I raise it
hallelu my weapon is
m i raise it
[Music]
hallelu Heaven comes to fight for
me I'm going to sing in the middle of
the
storm louder and louder OU you're going
to hear my Praises Roar Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
[Music]
alive I raise
[Applause]
hallelu with everything inside of me
I'll raise it
hallelu I will watch The Darkness
flee I will raise it
hallelu in the middle of the
[Music]
mystery it
Hallelujah
fear you lost your hold on
[Music]
me I'm going to sing in the middle of
the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Ro Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
alive I'm going to sing in the middle of
the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Ro Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
alive sing a little
louder
louder sing a little
louder in the presence of my enemies
sing a little
louder louder than the unbel sing a
little
louder my weapon is a Melody sing a
little louder
heaves to fight for me sing a little
louder sing a little
louder I'm going to sing in the middle
of the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Roar Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is alive
going to sing in the middle of the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Roar Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
alive raise the
Hallelujah I raise the
Hallelujah
Hallelujah raise
hallelujah
hallelujah the
Hallelujah PR the
Hallelujah all right kiddos you are
dismissed you may follow your teachers
into their classrooms we've got
got um second through sixth grade over
here we've got four yearolds through
first grade over here and the code is
1862 thank you Whitney and El Johnson
Anna and Devin over here with our big
kids Angie Rollins in the back Nursery
with our babies thank you guys so so
much all right Eve you want to lead us
in the prayers of the people
tonight we are going to participate in
something that throughout Christian
history has been known as the prayers of
the people we will Begin by reading a
prayer aloud together and then we will
leave space for you to say a name or
situation that you would like us to hold
in prayer before God we ask that you
only say their name to protect their
privacy in case the situation isn't
something they want to know publicly if
you are watching online please join in
by leaving a comment comment and we will
share those uh with the room once
everyone has had an opportunity to
participate we will close with
prayer for the city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in it we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick the Widow and
orphan for the injured and suff
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those who are struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know you love us and that you hear us so
we lift these names and situations up to
you
[Music]
share
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they might
have life and light healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
amen
God I look to
you I won't be
overwhelmed give me
Vision to see things like you do Lord I
look to you you where my help comes
from give me
wisdom
you know just what to do God I love to
you
overwhel God I look to you you won be
overwhelmed give me
Vision to see things like you do God I
look to you you're where my help comes
from give me
wisdom you know just what to do I will
love you Lord my
[Music]
strength I will love you Lord my
shield I Love You Lord my
rock forever all my days I will love you
God God I love to you I won't be
overwhelmed me
Vision to see things like you do God I
look to you you're where my help comes
from give me
wisdom you know just what to do I will
love you Lord my
strength I will love you Lord my
shield I will love you Lord my rock
forever all my days I will love you God
hallelujah
hallelu our god
reigns
hallelujah our god
reigns forever all my days
hallelujah
w
[Music]
oh
forever all my days
hallelujah I will love you Lord my
strength I will love you Lord my
shield I will love you Lord my rock for
forever all my days I will love you
God forever all my days I will love you
[Music]
God
this uh next song is really important to
the youth group it's um I stumbled upon
it in like a really hard time of my life
and um one thing that I didn't have
growing up in my church family was that
um environment where it's like okay to
question your faith
or just be real with how you're
struggling or be real with what your
your questions are and um I've always
wanted to like emphasize that with our
group that it's safe to ask those
questions it's okay to ask God for Faith
it's because out of everyone you can lie
to everybody in the face but God knows
like that you're questioning anyway so
why not ask for help or faith
I need
you to soften my heart and break meart I
need
[Music]
you to open my eyes to see that you're
shap in my
life oh I
am I
[Music]
surrender Give Me Faith to trust what
you
say they are good your love
is I'm broken inside I give you my
[Music]
love I need
you to soften my heart and break me part
I need
you to pierce through the dark and
cleanse every part of
me all I
am I
Surrender
Give Me Faith to trust what you
say they are good your love is
great I'm broken inside I give you my
love give
me trust what you
say that you're good
your love is
great I'm broken inside I give you my
life
[Music]
yours I may be
weak your spirit strong in me my flesh
may
fail my God you never will I may be
weak your spirit strong in me My Flesh
may
fail my God you never will I may be
weak your spirit strong in me my flesh
may
fail my God you never will I be
weak your spirit strong in me my flesh
may
fail my God you never will give me
Faith Give Me Faith
Give Me
Faith all right God we thank you for
tonight we thank you for this time and
God we just pray for the words that are
to follow and um we open our hearts to
you in Jesus name amen you may be
seated oh talk with the people around
you guys welcome
them what are y'all doing always so
talkative except for the one time I need
[Music]
you
okay
transitioning hi everybody my name is
Michael um if you haven't met me yet
um okay uh last time I spoke up here
about our youth and I'm sure I'll
probably say it again every single time
I'm up here speaking about youth but um
being a part of the students and leaders
has been one of the most fulfilling
Journeys that I've ever taken in my
life um my main goal going into to
provide a safe space um one that like
I'm sure a lot of queer adults in here
might not have um they always uh it like
growing up it always felt like church
and M those things couldn't meet but
um I've I've always wanted to in still
in our students that you can lean on me
and other people of the faith in your
queerness and strength and support in
that but um what I didn't expect was
that I would
be and Gathering so much support and
strength from them
too um this last year has been like a
really
um I don't know I I like had a meltdown
last Sunday
and I don't know what I was so close to
not coming to church and every single
time that I feel like I'm not going to I
just go I'm really really
um I'm losing all my words um but it was
a really good decision and I come up and
hug me was our next speaker
Eden and Eden said something that made
me he said I look up to you so much and
those are words that I never like did a
feel I remember like as
soon going I don't know like growing up
as a teenager going to my friend's house
I was a good student I
you know I was a good kid but as soon as
I started kind of leaning into my
queerness and expressing my identity in
that people's parents didn't want me
over anymore
um changes you a lot as a kid so to hear
like a kid tell you like I look up to
you it's for me and it gave me so much
strength and I'm so glad that I could
give it back to you
um because you have powerful strength
about you in the giggle I didn't know I
never know that a giggle could be so
strong to come Eve will be or Eden will
be talking about some really heavy stuff
today um but the fact that like you
can't every single um youth Sunday and
you laughed with me you cracked jokes at
me you made fun of me a
lot yeah it's okay um my therapist loves
you no um but
uh this I admire you you so much and the
strength that
you I I want to be where you want to
grow
up yeah uh Eden is one of my favorite
people in the world and I'm so glad that
you guys get to hear what he has
to guys right
um full warning I probably um will be
crying I was already tearing up M right
now um that
I like I was like prepared to cry but
not like not like immediately after I
was singing anyway um okay so as Michael
said Eden I'm 17 years old um I go to
Allen High School I'm a
senior so going to
college thank you Maggie so um and if
you have it
um I'm
[Music]
friend I sorry I'm a I'm a a youth or a
like Pastor or um I work with kids all
the time so this morning it was lots of
oh you know things that you need to keep
kids engaged so I I need to turn that
off a little bit but
um um if you've never gotten to speak
with me my friends would describe me as
outgo
and spontaneous and funny Maggie laughs
at all my jokes so I would consider that
a win my number one fan right
there
but um since hearing about you Sunday I
kind of knew I wanted to like I said
like I'm a Sunday school teacher and I
have
been for a year actually now and it's
been great like the slid says I love my
life right work with kids all the time
and it is my absolute pride and joy I
love my kids so much by the way um I
love my kids so much um and I think I
think talking about Jesus something so
meaningful to me makes me love my job
even more I can't describe a more
perfect thing for me to get paid to do
um and wake up every Sund morning 6:00
in the morning guys and and work with
children um they can be a lot I love
them to death um but in the same breath
um I I'm struggling um I struggle to
read my Bible I struggle to make time
for Jesus I struggle with my faith I
struggle with anxiety and pain and I
struggle to find joy and I'm going
through it so um just for a little
backstory um my mom things are Rocky
with her right now um if you're in my
life personally you you know um but my
mom has um abused me verbally since um I
um she um she made me feel like I was
never good enough I was never loved um
and I remember since I was really little
pring to have a new mom for Christmas um
and I don't I don't know any kid like
that were you even know the word abuse
you just
know I want this you know like and I
didn't realize that it ran that
deep um so I I also remember lying awake
and thinking that if my own mom couldn't
love me then who could one person who's
supposed to be there for you the one
person who's supposed to love you
unconditionally and that um and now I'm
17 and in
therapy so fun in therapy since fourth
grade therapy
lovers yep I've been in therapy since
fourth
grade um I don't know if any of y'all
can beat that um I will take it as a
challenge tell me after um but who's in
therapy since apparently um and many
people um would think that me from
believing in God um
and think thoughts like why is God put
this um and why is a God that's so good
um just you
know um I was I was really in the depths
and then in ninth grade a relationship
that was toxic at best and then abusive
at worst they told me after a week of
meeting me okay and my thought was oh my
gosh someone finally loves right what
what could go wrong
Maggie what could go wrong right and
dandy a lot um spoiler alert that that
relationship didn't as you can see by
the slides or the first slide um with me
and my girlfriend
um that that relationship not work um
because um and I I want to be vulnerable
right now and real um but I don't want
to trigger anyone and I want to like be
care with how I use my words right now
and so I'm not going to go into
details but they used my my mom
instilled to me um and took advantage of
me and manipulated me into sex every
other day day for
months um
and out of that
um it it does take a toll on you if
you've ever wanted to know it it it
really does um and when when I
thought um would be to go to the cops um
and they when I went to the cops um they
said that there wasn't enough proof to
prosecute on that I said
yes and they can't prove that it was my
word against
theirs um and I was I was really lost
thought that this this is the way out
this is the
way to solve everything um they'll
they'll fix it and all feel so much
better this will be the changing point
and it didn't it it failed
me um if if that isn't bad enough
um one of the other worst Parts um but
one of the other worst Parts was um
seeing them at school so they were
during the same period in the classroom
next door to me um and if you don't know
Allen ISD we um we have separate
campuses so it wasn't I could go a
different way and they could go a
different way and I could avoid them
this was a had to walk the exact same
way and um that
was I I was afraid to leave my classroom
um it it really with my learning um I
was afraid to go to the bathroom alone
which
I would think you shouldn't have to be
but I
was um I was do and what they would
say and this
fear turned into anger really quickly
and really really deep anger really
deep-seated
and um how can somebody do something and
face no
consequences and think that they did
nothing wrong and I heard in the back
that I needed to forgive this person and
I pushed it off I know I made excuses
like I haven't healed yet I haven't
processed my trauma like
place um how can I forgive someone who
has ruined my even sorry and um that
voice kept telling me that forgiveness
or isn't saying that the action is okay
or
acceptable but it's a way for you to
carry your burden
so um this is where I want to talk about
since um Maggie of voice memo a little
while ago I was driving on the highway
had this epiphany of this verse and I
was and I was think I realized that
maybe I had been um taking it out of
context it's um um
1129 through3 it says take my yoke upon
you and learn of me weak and lowly in
heart and you shall find rest unto your
souls for my yoke is and his
light so I thought and growing up I
don't even know if I was kind of
subliminal maybe um that this meant that
I had to give all of my and he would
take everything and I would ever have to
think about it
again and if I'm means I'm just not
letting God take control enough you know
I just don't have enough Faith you know
put more faith in him and just leave my
burdens all to him and I won't wait I
will never worry
again um but God didn't say I would take
your yoke completely all by myself and
if you do it right you'll never worry
again a yoke is for two
oxen two um that load evenly he didn't
say that I will take away the pain but
he says that he will he tells us that he
will meet us right where we are he
doesn't say my yoke is wores my yoke
weighs nothing he says it's light
this is where I started and I let God
share in my pain God gives us rest when
we give in and say Jesus I
can't and here's what I learned here's
what I learned God didn't put to judge
but to
love
um and it's them I sat for a really long
time having deep thoughts
about what I would do if I got a
chance with them and for them to listen
to me and if I were to to just talk had
all they got to do was listen what I
would say and I racked my brain I
thought and I thought and I
thought
and and
realize is that um that nothing I say or
do will ever ever make them hurt like
they made me hurt
nothing um and I I can I can tell them
how they hurt me I can tell them how
it's impacted my life impacted my
relationships um my romantic ones
my my
confidence um
and going to change what happened to me
and I can't get them to make me or like
they made me
hurt
um
and honestly it's burden to carry it's
not my job to make them feel the hurt
that they made me
feel um and here I wrote Jesus will
bring Justice and I will bring
love and God ever asks me to do he
doesn't ask me for anything more than
that cuz I
person understand what it was like to
hurt I wanted them to apologize
reparations aelle wouldn't hurt
um
but but I can't force them to do any of
that in love and as hard as that
is um that's
I mean I want to do so much more I want
to have things in my control and it
truly just is it truly isn't and
that's that's been one of the scariest
so most freeing things that has ever
happened to
me
um um it was and it was such a hurdle to
give love when all I want and it freed
me
Jesus freed me I started to have less
anxiety when I saw them and I had more
inner PE
PE this started a lot with just
repeating that already on my side that I
don't have to I don't have to fight for
him to um be on my side that I'm already
guarded by his love and there's nothing
that he that do that can hurt me already
than they already
have and I
think um I started
also toay pray for um because I know
that things haven't been the easiest for
them and that's not a
justification
it's it's just I
mean
um
and this is also a person who is a child
of God um as and I struggled I strugg
lot um
and this is a person that Jesus died for
and he didn't get on that cross and died
just for me because I'm so me so
much um because he loves this person
too and despite what they did Jesus
doesn't love this person any less and
so um and he loves this person so much
that he Di and he do it over and over
and over again and this anger really
told
me um and by proxy this person was able
to control my emotions by stepping into
a shared space I got upset and angry I
got upset and angry
with
um and
um in at them was them continuing to
control
me
um I felt like they were controlling my
emotions um they controlled whether or
not I had a good day by just
existing um in
me um but most of all it really
controlled my about the mission that
Jesus has sent me on this Earth for and
that's to love and as hard as that can
be sometimes um and God doesn't ask me
to get this person to take
accountability that's that's not my
burden to carry that's something I don't
have to worry about because Jesus has it
covered and all I have to do and by
learning to love I no longer let them
control my my anger and my my
fear um and it's one of the most freeing
things I've learned um recently I've
been reading a book called everybody
always um becoming of setbacks and
difficult people by Bob Goff it's a
really good book guys um and something
that fundamentally changed how I view
this person beautifully in this
book it
reads well you should give wide birth to
you bet there are people in my life and
yours toxic and Delight in sowing
Discord wherever they go God gave us
discern use it as we live our
lives and then it goes on to say he's us
love and understanding and kindness and
the ability to
forgive which power we so often leave
untapped there's a difference between
good judg
judgement the trick is to use lots of
the first and go a little lighter on the
second I felt like I was living in
judgment and that's not a healthy place
um and in case you want to um take title
because that's just chapter one guys
that's chap one so it gets really good
but um everybody always Bob offl um and
anyway um
so I'm a firm believer that um Jesus
calls us to and this is a this is a
phrase um that I've been
going back then again and I
know um I've been struggling with this
but also like when I knew that you
Sunday was like I need to tell everyone
that Jesus Jesus calls us to do the
uncomfortable because people stay in
their comfort zone so often um and
that's not
what and Jesus knows us Jesus knows us
and he knows that us out of our comfort
zones onto the water and that is how we
learn so fast forward to my faith
growing and I can't tell you how it um I
know that you can look in the face of
evil and it gives you a story things
that are
unspeakable and they either tear you
away from or drive you and I thank God
every day that it did not tear me away
from him but in
fact Joseph looked into the face of evil
and he forgave his brothers and that's
what we've been talking about in youth
um it's all about
perspective in in in um my perspective
this is a person who has hurt me Beyond
repair and sees And yet when we see
Through The Eyes Of God God sees as a
person who he down for and like I said
that's one of the things that I've
struggled but it's also been really
freeing
too what this person intended has been
one of the greatest lessons in my life
and I'm not saying that it was good
grateful for my sexual assault or that
it was a great thing and that if
something similar like like this
happened to you that you should already
and be on the same timeline as me but
I'm saying that there is a pris taught
me Genesis
5020 you intended to harm me it for
good um a phrase a phrase that I um this
by is not God God ordained but God
transformed similar about a few weeks
ago
um and so I know there probably someone
here maybe multiple people here that
thinks oh my gosh this e
is um and everyone in youth would kind
of tell you yeah it's kind of a
resounding yes in on that front um in in
all seriousness I'd never ever ever be
right here saying this that I forgave
this person um I think it was about a
year ago now that um I burst left the
room um when we were in
youth um it was
about something wrong or graphic or
anything like that it could not imagine
what forgiveness looked like I didn't
think about
forgiveness I didn't think it was
possible and yet God makes and it didn't
happen
overnight but
and I know that there's
probably statistically PE speaking
there's a person in this room who has
gone through something
similar and I just want to take time and
space to see and that um it's not your
fault it's not your
fault um and it was thing to do at first
to think that the same God who
you loves this person who did Evil to
you and yet it's one of the most
beautiful strengthening and I've ever
done but I can't take all the credit for
it
and one of the most beautiful Parts
about it is community I open been
talking about my mom and things are
still really rough on that front are
getting divorced and it's getting really
nasty um
because my mom moved in and guess who I
found with an open heart and Open
Arms G and Garen and
Garen Karen and
Gary sorry I hope you enjoy the pictures
of
there the other one is the one of Karen
is courtesy of Matthew
Miner was the one of Gary but I was
there they let me stay in their house um
and they were planning on long-term
until a miracle happened and my mom
moved
out um we did for a while and I I guess
you can figure out how that went based
on the fact not together
anymore
um I knew I would do
um one of the only things that 60
Minutes was knowing that I could go over
to the miner's house after and
carry
um and that's been reassuring to me that
I always always have a place to go you
so much if that isn't
apparent seriously if you've never
gotten a hug from Karen Miner you're
missing
out listening ears open hearts and ice
cream was something I
got on the regular and at the miners and
I mean Karen posted me for a national
Sun's day cried
um I never thought that I would have mom
who left
me
and I have so
many
um and you know who gave me um family
because I didn't feel like I had a
family Maggie I hope you these pictures
too she was not these slides when I
showed them to
her but thank you long on your Maggie
SL
it really brings me joy okay and and
Mindy and Brett and Josh and their
family you also like that picture of Eve
um I think it's really
great did
you that they have seven kids living
Under One Roof guys I love kid
um
soccer and volleyball practice that's
piano lessons and vending machine and
yet they made time for me almost every
week in their home without hesit Maggie
and I tend to have the best
conversations that flow so naturally and
allow me to be so vulnerable in a way
that I just wouldn't get other
17-year-old um or any anybody for for
that matter I often struggle to leave
and it's common for me to miss my
curfew I will lose track of time or I
will be trying to leave for up to an
hour build into another deep and
beautiful conversation that I have so
much input for um yeah my dad is not a
big fan of the missing curfew
part and then Abby Michael and Marissa
um they have been
they've been
dedicated um at youth to make um and I
look up to them in so many ways Abby
always have um empathy and wisdom to
share and she gives us space to um give
our own thoughts which um I mean it can
to feel overlooked as a teenager and
that and let matter and that's I've
never felt that um in youth along with
picking out fun games that I've laughed
so hard at and so has Eve sometimes so
hard she pees
herself We Do It um a
little Michael's
going Michael brings their talent on
guitar and under pitch harmonies never
seem to get
old I truly and I can tell this person
is going places I want to be like them
and so Marissa is such a
sweetheart and she's one of the most
humble met you're probably like shying
away in the corner like don't look at me
guys she's so humble
um and she's here all Sunday often the
first first to enter setting up on her
hands and knees to V and always the last
to leave at youth um she has stayed for
up to watching me and maew um talk in
the car making sure we're safe um guys
that's 900 p.m. for you guys um so from
2: to 9: so truly a mama bear um
Matthew yeah thank you for these
pictures um truly my best friend we've
spent hours upon hours upon Hours hard
and talking um many times tears were
included and at this point um always
taking time for me with his busy
schedule brother in the best ways and in
The Bullying
ways um he will be so and will listen to
me with an open heart this church is
truly Jesus Christ I never thought I'd
have a loving
family and here they are I have no
doubts of how precious I am and I have
and I'm love and that's not an assurance
that you often get with a Teen centry um
let alone someone who's
trans um ask for a better support system
while going through the worst patches in
my life all these people who invite me
into their homes their family events
their hearts this church has truly
changed my life and I don't know where I
would be um and I don't say that lightly
I haven't even gotten to yet um and I
don't think I have time but on top of
this one of the most um affirming people
uh group of people that I've ever ready
to share their heart and love for god um
an
uncondition Shiloh um I want to give a
special shout out to is Mindy s who
always um uses Heim pronouns for me
over and has never messed up and
something about that so much the table
has healed so much of my church hurt for
growing up in a non-affirming
space what a blessing truly is of all of
these people and see Jesus in each and
every one of
them it's truly an unspeakable gift that
I have I have to express my
gratitude
um and um something about being in a
queer affirming church when you didn't
something like this could even
exist changes
you Earth to love to love the people
that are easy to love and to love the
people who are hard to love I think the
greatest thing I've seen at the
table is this Jesus to do the
uncomfortable Jesus calls us to love
further than we want to sometimes that's
what I've seen with the table it's
vulnerable to let someone dinners with
you every week it's vulnerable to let
someone live with you it's vulner be in
a CER firming space and to share love
and that's exactly me to do and the
table has lived out thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
do
okay okay
Hank that was
awesome hi everyone uh here we do what's
called an Open Table uh means that uh
anyone and everyone is welcome to join
and part um it doesn't matter
that we all think and feel differently
welcome to come and
join um we wine and the white is grape
juice and the bread is
glutenfree table not of the church but
of the
Lord and it is made him and want to love
him
more so come uh you who have much faith
and you who have little you and you who
have not been here
often you who have who have
failed sorry I'm blanking
um come because it is the Lord who
invites you and it is uh you should meet
him thank
you
for
[Music]
it's
for
[Music]
for all right um this last song I just
want to invite you to um it's a new song
that we haven't done before it's called
why but um and um I came across it about
a month ago or two now um and I just I
love how this resonates um with me and I
just invite you to um your heart and um
listen truly to what the lyrics have to
[Music]
so why can
not
[Music]
already
out manys have
been can I praise you
enough so
here's
why you love you love me
you never
know
why love me like you love me
love
gold
know
why
love
[Music]
like
Joy
[Music]
does
come the places
are your love doesn't
look like
Inwood you don't walk out it's that's
when I need you the
[Music]
most
know
[Music]
why
silver I ever know you never know
[Music]
never
know
[Music]
never even when I you love even when I
curse your name even when I broke your
[Music]
heart when I make myed in hell even when
I don't
love you love Cut and Run you
love you
love
[Music]
why like you
love never know
why like you love me better than
Sil better than gold
[Music]
like you
love I never
[Music]
know
[Applause]
all
right think do we have a mic for Hank
we're gonna let Hank the way
out give you all before
um uh if you'd like to take a posture of
re receiving if you feel
comfortable
you are a child of God you are a child
of God true on your best days and this
is especially true on your worst days go
into your week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and every go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are worth you are accepted
just as you are and go filled with these
same Gifts of GRA and unconditional love
with everyone you come in contact with
have a good
[Music]
night you love you love your love is
better
[Music]
Sil never
know